oh you know how ever since streaming
you've been paying us like yeah
it's hilarious right can you stop sure
yeah I can stop paying you uh we'll hire
robots instead we're going on strike
okay have fun that's it that's all
you're gonna say oh sorry I hope you
lose your house
what hey ever since streaming you've
been paying us like I know it's
hilarious oh wait you're the famous ones
yeah can you pay us now I'll do you one
better we'll clone your likeness into an
AI and control you like a meat puppet
I'm going on strike okay have fun we're
not writers we're famous you need us I
know you're probably right and this will
destroy the industry and put so many
people out of work then why are you
doing this
uh I'm evil oh that that makes sense
yeah